since russia invaded ukraine more than
two million people have fled the country
most of them to the eu
members praised the support of
neighbouring countries and debated how
to strengthen europe's defense with
estonian prime minister kaya kalas
a nation of strong women is how writer
oksana zabushko described ukraine
marking a somber international women's
day on the 8th of march she paid tribute
to their courage taking up arms to
defend their homeland and protect their
children
parliament expressed alarm that fake
news websites targeting europe makes 65
million euros a year from advertising
it's called for stronger eu defenses
against disinformation and interference
in european democracies from autocratic
regimes like russia and china
between 2011 and 2019 more than 130 000
foreign nationals bought eu citizenship
or residency through investment schemes
meps called for a ban on golden
passports saying they present serious
security risks
the quantity of lithium batteries
needing recycling is expected to
increase 700 fold over the next two
decades parliament set out its position
on new rules to regulate the design
production and disposal of batteries
[Music]
you